[Music]
on this Tuesday night support for
Canadian seniors how much it is and
whether the Prime Minister's latest
pledge is enough as calls amplify for
long-term solutions to the crisis inside
care homes this is a tragedy the risk of
reopening a fresh warning from one of
America's top doctors a possible vaccine
for Kovac 19 being tested in Canada the
collaboration between Canada and a
Chinese lab and fairs without
necessities what the pandemic needs for
these pandas
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots of developments to get you on this
Tuesday from a new deal to test a
possible vaccine here in Canada to an
appeal in Quebec to wear masks in public
and there's new support for seniors
struggling to make ends meet the federal
government is giving out one-time
payments of up to five hundred dollars
to help cover expenses Canadians who
receive old age security will get an
automatic top-up of three hundred
dollars those eligible for guaranteed
income supplement or GIS will get an
additional two hundred dollars about six
point seven million Canadians are
expected to receive the payments it's
estimated to be worth about two point
five billion dollars that money will
help some but it does nothing for the
thousands of people trapped inside
long-term care homes unable to visit
family and vulnerable to the worst kovat
19 outbreaks in canada kovat 19 has
exposed some uncomfortable truths about
our society we've seen heartbreaking
tragedies in long-term care facilities
and nursing homes right across the
country and in the coming months the
federal government will be there to help
the provinces find lasting solutions to
give you a picture of how people living
in long-term care have been affected of
the more than 50 100 people who have
died of kovat 19 in Canada over 80
percent were people living in care homes
across the country more than 71 thousand
people have now tested positive for the
virus about 20 percent of those cases
are linked to long-term care long-term
care homes are likely to be the last
places where public health restrictions
get lifted we'll get to that in just a
moment but first David akin has details
on the new support for Canadian seniors
and whether it's enough for many seniors
it's about time seniors have been
flooding mp's offices with demands for
more health we are hearing from seniors
across the country thousands of emails
and and phone calls but the government
does not believe seniors need the same
kind of help already provided to
employees students or small business
owners who have lost all of their
income instead the government believes
seniors on a fixed income
need help with higher monthly expenses
we're announcing more help because we
recognize that every week
seniors are out of pocket a little bit
more some examples higher drug
dispensing costs because of more
frequent drugstore trips and higher
transportation costs as seniors avoid
the health risk on public transit and
rely more on taxis and on delivery
services meanwhile poverty among seniors
and especially female seniors remains a
problem the maximum old age security
benefit is just over six hundred and
thirteen dollars a month while the
maximum guaranteed income supplement
available to the lowest income seniors
is just over nine hundred and sixteen
dollars a month that plus a Canada
Pension Plan payment is all that more
than 1.6 million seniors rely on for
their total monthly income opposition
parties are pushing the government to do
more the help right now that they've
offered is not enough and it's also not
permanent we need to see a permitted
increase in supports for seniors they
can live with dignity and respect and
seniors advocacy groups like carp
remember that the Trudeau Liberals have
yet to make good on campaign promises to
boost both old age security and Canada
Pension Plan benefits we want that to
come in so they have a permanent
increase in the OAS the CPP not the
temporary yeah 500 that's not going to
help seniors the long run and in the
meantime no date has yet been set when
the new one-time-only checks will be
sent out the government will only say
that it will be within weeks
David akin Global News Ottawa as we've
said the people most vulnerable to Kovac
19 in Canada are living in long-term
care homes the problems there are
long-standing and have been laid bare by
this pandemic tonight Mike Armstrong
looks at the deadly deficiencies and the
demands for change
even before kovat 19 hit canada there
were warnings about what it could mean
for seniors and seniors residences
despite that the virus was still able to
get into hundreds of residences across
Canada patients rights advocate Paul
Brunei says in some facilities kovat 19
spread like a brushfire because
governments were asleep at the wheel
when we woke up fire was already in
long-term facilities that's probably
around 2 months late now Brunei is one
of the people who've been sounding the
alarm about long-term care facilities
for years what the crisis has done is
exposed the fragility of the system and
as a result politicians now see the
flaws as well there are serious
underlying challenges facing these
facilities this is a tragedy the federal
government is now promising a review of
what went wrong as are several provinces
one of the major issues many point to is
labor a recent study by a Canadian
think-tank calls for a heavy investment
in staffing in terms of their numbers in
terms of their education and training in
terms of the autonomy we give them a
whole range of things
there are also calls for more inspectors
and inspections in Quebec there are
reports this week some facilities hadn't
been visited in as much as five years
that's actually not far off from what
the current rules require you have to be
inspected that please one time every
three years
one option Quebec's premier has floated
is the government taking over private
residences
well critics say that would be like
nationalizing the horror stories that
they hear more complaints about public
facilities than private ones you are not
being even doing the right job and the
public and you want to nationalize it I
don't want that no no
the issue will be front and center
Wednesday in Ottawa the House of Commons
Health Committee is holding a hearing
focused specifically on long-term care
facilities and seniors Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal for the first time
since the pandemic was declared québec's
premier fresh well ago showed up at his
daily press briefing wearing a mask Lego
is now strongly recommending Quebecers
wear a mask when they leave home to help
reduce the spread of the virus it is not
mandatory in Quebec partly because of a
supply shortage Lego says wearing masks
does not take the place of proper
hand-washing and physical distancing
where possible staff entering the West
Wing of the White House are now required
to wear masks and anyone who gets near
the president must be tested it's a
reflection of how seriously the White
House is now taking the risk most
American states are now pressing ahead
with plans to loosen public health
restrictions and today dr. Anthony Fauci
who has served under six presidents
cautioned against rushing to reopen and
what it could lead to Jackson prosecco
reports randomized trial the first
congressional hearing of the coronavirus
era brought little good news there is a
real risk that you will trigger an
outbreak you may not be able to control
with witnesses appearing from their
homes Senators press them on what it
will take to reopen a nation with the
highest number of cases and deaths in
the world staying at home indefinitely
is not the solution to this pandemic the
experts world repeatedly about the risks
of relaxing measures too quickly and
suggested the official death toll of
more than 80,000 is likely missing the
true scale of the pandemic I think you
are correct if the number is likely
higher I don't know exactly what was
that tire but almost certainly is higher
one Republican senator who contracted
the virus himself cast doubt on those
words of caution I don't think you're
the end-all I don't think you're the one
person that gets to make a decision to
be the end-all and only voice of this
I'm a scientist a physician and a public
health official I give advice according
to the bed
scientific evidence the head of the
Centers for Disease Control said the US
needs to increase contact tracing by
five to ten fold to prevent future
outbreaks there were warnings that a
vaccine won't be ready if children are
sent back to school in the fall a worry
as cases of a mysterious inflammatory
illness linked to kovat 19 rise in young
people we have met the moment and we
have prevailed
all of it contradicts the message
delivered by President Donald Trump just
24 hours earlier as he touted the
increase in testing in the US I find our
testing record nothing to celebrate
whatsoever Jackson not many people
contradict the president without getting
fired has dr. faux cheap been sidelined
or is he still the voice of reason
influencing President Trump well Donna
he's certainly seen his role change in
recent weeks he is less visible there
are no more daily White House
coronavirus briefings voci is though
still working behind the scenes inside
the White House to help shape policy we
should point out though a poll that came
out today is not likely to make the
president happy
it shows 67 percent of Americans trust
Anthony foutch II only 36 percent trust
the information they're getting from the
president right now Jackson Prosecco in
Washington thanks it's hoped gradually
easing restrictions will lessen the
likelihood of a new wave of community
transmission here in Canada as the
provinces and territories take the first
steps to reopen the economy one of the
things they're watching is the
reproduction rate of Coe bid 19 which
helps predict how quickly infections can
spread Eric Sorenson explains how it
works and what it indicates as Canada
eases restrictions the concern is the
corona virus infection will spread in
the community countries are watching
each other to see what works and what
doesn't
at the forefront Germany has opened bars
shops in some schools even gyms with
their heavy breathing and shared
equipment but already Germany is seeing
a new rise in the spread of kovat 19 the
product - the reproduction rate our said
this health official last week was below
one but this week our is up to 1.1 thus
the little tones we are taking very
seriously the reproduction factor he
says because our above one is the
threshold for trouble the R is a
measurement of diseases ability to
explode in your community are the
reproduction number for covin works like
this
if one infected person passes on the
virus to one other R is one if it's
passed on to two others R is 2 and that
is very bad now if you have physical
distancing and the infected person
passes on to say on average just point
five other people the R is 0.5 and that
is very good
here's why the population at large if
you have 1,000 infected people they will
infect that are to 2,000 other people
and in the next round after that they'll
infect 4000 now if it's are 0.5 that
1000 will infect only 500 and the 500
will infect only 250 if you have five
more rounds of infections while an R -
that number will climb to above a
hundred and twenty thousand where is it
for 0.5 it will drop to 8
so our below 1 or above 1 is the
difference between exponential growth or
the virus gradually disappearing where
is Canada right now the our reproductive
number is estimated at 0.66 well below 1
in fact every province is doing
relatively well many with very few cases
but experts say it's vital to keep
physical distancing I think run a good
path towards keeping that reproduction
below as social life restarts and arcane
but simple formula the our number can
tell us how we're doing
Erik Sorensen Global News Toronto Canada
is collaborating with a Chinese lab to
begin human trials of a vaccine
candidate for Kovac 19 here
Canada the national research council has
made an agreement with Cansino biologics
in China a laboratory it's worked with
since 2013 human clinical trials of a
possible vaccine are already in their
second phase in China the NRC is hoping
to expedite phase one and two trials
here in Canada Chinese researchers
created this potential vaccine using
living cells that were originally grown
by NRC scientists and that were used to
develop the Ebola vaccine there is a lot
of complementarity and expertise and
knowledge that we have about this
vaccine and we are quite confident that
we will be able to produce this vaccine
easily in our facilities if the human
clinical trial proceeds and is
successful the vaccine could be
available for emergency use in Canada by
the fall
Kensei now needs approval from Health
Canada to begin the trials here it's
hoped to have a made in Canada vaccine
the federal government is earmarked 44
million dollars to upgrade manufacturing
capabilities at the NRC production
facility in Montreal eight other
vaccines have reached the stage of human
clinical trials including in the US
Germany and the UK and there are about
100 other potential vaccines being
worked on there in the earlier stages of
development that's according to the
World Health Organization reaching the
stage of human trials does not mean
success is guaranteed most trials fail
and it usually takes years for a new
vaccine to be approved for use an
aggressive round of testing is going to
begin in Wuhan China where the first
cases of kovat 19 were discovered and
where the world's first locked-down
happened a cluster of six new cases of
kovat 19 were discovered in Wuhan it's
feared the virus could begin spreading
again in the community so a plan is
being made to test all of Wu Hans eleven
million residents within ten days a
Canadian rock star condemned coming up
Bryan Adams tirade and the tidal wave of
criticism
in Nova Scotia investigators are trying
to figure out how the man behind one of
this country's worst mass killings was
able to plan his deadly rampage without
getting caught as Ross Lord reports new
photos of the killers home may offer
some clues photos obtained by global
news show the gunman's home in importer
pick last November five months before
his rampage inside there are images of a
spacious bar another picture shows a
series of at least eight motorcycles
then there's this one a car decorated
like an RCMP cruiser with this same
identifying number - 8 b11 as this car
the one the gunman drove during the
killing spree the contractor who took
the pictures wishes to remain anonymous
but says he turned them over to
investigators shortly after the massacre
to gain insight into the killer's
actions the RCMP says it will conduct a
psychological autopsy such autopsies
examine a wide range of issues
everything from how a killer relates to
others two warning signs to abuse he
might have perpetrated or suffered
previously psychologists who advocate
for psychological autopsies say
examining killers more closely can save
lives I think it's important that we as
Canadians commit to a course of action
to use the event support to lower the
probability that this ever happens again
some pieces of the puzzle are coming
into focus the Mounties say they've
identified this supplier that made the
RCMP decals on the killer's car the
decals were actually produced without
the business owners consent now the
business owner and the person who
created decals are cooperating with
police investigators say witnesses have
told them the gunman had a large supply
of gasoline in Porter Peck they believe
he used it as an accelerant to start
fires during the rampage Ross lower
Global News Windsor Nova Scotia
ahead speaking out about surveillance
from China a Chinese Canadian woman says
she's being targeted on academic
bryan adams has learned a lesson The
Canadian singer-songwriter has
apologized after his Instagram post was
condemned by people around the world as
racist I'm going to read it so apologies
in advance
Adams blames the Kovach 19 pandemic on
some effing fat-eating wet market animal
selling virus making greedy bastards he
was lamenting the cancellation of a
concert series he was supposed to
perform at London's Royal Albert Hall
people called him crass and racist he
deleted that rant and posted this
apologies to any and all that took
offense to my posting yesterday no
excuse I just wanted to have a rant
about the horrible animal cruelty in
these wet markets being the possible
source of the virus and promote veganism
here's the thing according to the World
Health Organization all available
evidence is the virus did originate in
animals in China it could have come from
bats but it's still not certain
nor is it clear how and where the virus
jumped the species barrier to humans
there is no evidence it was made by
anyone Adam says he has love for all
people and that his thoughts are with
everyone dealing with this pandemic
around the world a Chinese Canadian
woman who is a vocal opponent of the
Chinese Communist Party says she and her
family are paying the price
anastasiya Lin was born in China and
emigrated to Canada at the age of 13 she
went on to win Miss World Canada and has
been outspoken about human rights abuses
in China and the so called United Front
that's the network's the Chinese
government uses to influence government
policy in the West
Robin Gill reports I am NOT anti China
Anastasia Lin knows Beijing has many
eyes on her especially when she gives
these speeches critical of the communist
regime censorship of information in
dangerous global health
now the corona virus outbreak is a
perfect example
but her blunt manner has consequences
back in China where she was born and
where her father still lives he's been
banned from leaving the country and the
family's business acquaintances are
visited by an agency known as the
United Front when the national security
agents invite you to drink tea it means
that they're going to meet up with you
issue a vague threat the United Front is
a tentacle of the Communist Party of
China and operates both at home and
abroad according to Amnesty
International the operatives allegedly
harass or threaten people of Chinese
heritage living in Canada to turn on
dissidents and shut down critics the way
they operate is through fear and greed
the two worst thing in human nature they
try to intimidate you if it doesn't work
they try to buy you off according to
security experts these so-called spies
are right here in Canada and our agents
of China's cold war with the West the
reports that we have are persons who
have been subject to harassment by
agents of the Chinese regime whether
they are persons in in Canada with
diplomatic protection because there are
more diplomats accredited to the
People's Republic of China in Canada
than all other countries the Chinese
embassy in Ottawa did not answer
requests from Global News to respond to
these allegations so we went to the
Prime Minister his response we will
continue to defend human rights while at
the same time looking to protect
Canadians everywhere around the world
Lin refuses to be silent and encourages
others to be just as vocal there are
already a lot of voices I just hope that
people will listen to there are people
listening but many are reporting back to
China
Robin Gill Global News Vancouver
bye-bye bears next why Calgary's giant
pandas are going home early
two pandas are packing up and going home
early the Calgary Zoo is sending its
giant pandas back to China because it
can't get a secure supply of bamboo to
feed them her Shan and da Mao arrived in
Canada in 2014 on loan from China and
are much loved they were supposed to
stay until 2023 but fresh bamboo has
been hard to get because of disrupted
flights and misdirected shipments we
have a responsibility to provide fresh
bamboo every single day and that's not
an option
and in this kovat environment it's it's
too risky
fresh bamboo makes up 99 percent of
their diet and an adult giant panda can
eat up to 40 kilograms of bamboo a day
the head of the zoo said it's incredibly
difficult to send them home but it's
best for their health and well-being and
that is global national for this Tuesday
May the 12th which is International Day
of the nurse the day chosen because it's
the birthday of Florence Nightingale the
British nurse was born 200 years ago
today and she was a trailblazer she took
care of soldiers during the Crimean War
and established high standards for
Nursing including hand-washing and
proper hygiene simple things that save
lives and are just as important today
thanks for watching bye bye
[Music]